I have breast cancer that it has met to the bone. Right now I'm taking Zometa
Inclusion. So Zometa is a class of drugs. This is the brand name of the drug.
Zometa helps in the idea of Zometa helps increase bone density.
Now Zometa is a class of drugs that came out years ago, 20 years ago I think.
And I have never been a fan of it because I think it's too technical but your bone has layers to it.
You have the outer part of the bone called the periosteum, osteo, osteo means bone, peri means outer, outer part of the bone periosteum.
And then you have the inner part of the bone called the endosteum.
The endosteum is really what you want to increase density.
That's what gives your bone strength. Not the periosteum. The purpose of the periosteum is for muscle attachment.
That's what it attaches to the periosteum. You don't want to increase the density of periosteum.
You want to increase the density of the endosteum.
The problem is Zometa and Zometa like drugs in that class increase the density of the periosteum.
This is very well documented. In that effect they started using Zometa when it first came out for osteoporosis.
The problem is several years after using it they did a five year study on women using the drug and they found that there was no decrease in the amount of fractures osteoporotic fractures pathological fractures.
So why is that they're taking this drug that's going to increase the density of the bone.
They found that it actually just increases the density of the periosteum making hard and brittle bones.
That effect it gets worse because it's like putting cellophators, sarandrap or all your bones so you can't even absorb things into the endosteum.
So I know oncologists are really big into using Zometa infusions when a person has vets to the bones.
In my opinion, I'm not a fan. I still think it helps at all.
So are there things from a natural perspective that you could take.
Yes, there is we have a bone building bundle in our stolen. So we that is a bundle that we use that we recommend specifically for this is I think there's three different nutritional products in that bone building bundle.
So you can look that up on the story.
Starting taking multiband lots of good start last week with 80k supreme that's good.
So the D is important to help get nutrition, get calcium into the bone and the multiband has a good balance of different multiband.
But I am ready to drop the eyebrows, the false max formal shots and Zometa can I drop all at once or should I drop one at a time.
I can't really legally comment on that.
That's something you're going to have to ask the prescribing doctor.
I can't really really say that about that.